>> Tucker: I BECOME A BETTER
MAN EVERY DAY.
>> Sean: WE START TONIGHT WITH
A FOX NEWS ALERT, THE PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP ANNOUNCED HE IS
RUNNING FOR REELECTION LAST
NIGHT, HE WILL JOIN US IN JUST A
FEW MINUTES, AN EXCLUSIVE
ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEW YOU DON'T
WANT TO MISS IT.
UNLIKE THE MEDIA MOB, WE WILL
LET HIM TALK AND WE AREN'T
PLAYING GOTCHA.
HE KICKED OFF HIS REELECTION
BID, A MASSIVE RALLY.
A 20,000 SEAT ARENA IN ORLANDO
PACKED TO THE BRIM, MORE THAN
150,000 PEOPLE WANTED TO BE
THERE AND MANY MORE STOOD IN AN
OVERFLOW AREA OUTSIDE WITH SOME
LITERALLY WAITING IN LINE OVER
40 PLUS HOURS JUST TO GET IN.
I GUESS THE GREATEST SHOW ON
EARTH CONSIDERING THERE IS NO
ELTON JOEL, BILLY JOHN,
JIMI HENDRIX, THE PRESIDENT'S
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF PUME
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF PUMD
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF PUMU
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF PUMP
SUPPORTERS, I WOULD SAY
IT'S FAIR TO COMPARE HIS CROWDS
TO ANY OF HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST,
TO ANY OF HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST2
TO ANY OF HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST4
DEMOCRATS WANT TO GO UP
AGAINST HIM IN THE NEXT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORA
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORP
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORC
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORA
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORU
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORC
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FORJ
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, LIKE FOR.
HAS HE EVER FILLED IN ARENA, ONE
TIME?
OBAMA DID, I DON'T THINK JOE
HAS.
ONLY 600 PEOPLE CAME TO HIS
FIRST CAMPAIGN RALLY.
ELIZABETH WARREN DID SLIGHTLY
BETTER, SHE HAD A WHOPPING 3,500
SUPPORTERS, THAT SHOWED UP IN
HER HOME STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS.
MEANWHILE, THE ONE TIME RISING
STAR OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
ROBERT FRANCIS, BETO, BOZO
O'ROURKE HE AMASSED 20,000
PEOPLE, ROUGHLY ONE 20TH THE
SIZE OF THE PRESIDENT'S RALLY,
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE ENTHUSIASM GAP IS MASSIVE
BUT NOT EVERYONE SEES THE
HANDWRITING ON THE WALL.
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS, SO CALLED
AND THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN LYING
TO YOU FOR TWO PLUS YEARS AND
HAVE PUSHED CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND HOAXES AND NEVER THOUGHT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD WIN, THEY USE
LAST NIGHTS RALLY TO TRASH THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS AND
BY THE WAY AS WE START THE SHOW
TONIGHT, I START WITH A
THANK YOU -- BECAUSE WE HAD WELL
OVER 5 MILLION PEOPLE JUST TUNE
INTO THIS ONE HOUR, NEVER MIND
TUCKER'S HOUR, NEVER MIND THE
OTHER CABLE CHANNELS.
NEVER MIND THE OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS, VERY IMPRESSIVE SHOWING
BY THE PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT.
WE AREN'T TO THE MEDIA, WE ARE
MORE THAN SMELLY PEOPLE WHO LIKE
WALMART WHO CLING TO OUR GUNS,
GOD, BIBLES, RELIGION, WE AREN'T
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES
ALTHOUGH SOME PEOPLE THINK SO
AND IT APPEARS THE MOB HAS
LEARNED POSITIVELY NOTHING FROM
2016, LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT TURNED INTO A "LOCK HER
UP" A CHANCE TONIGHT.
>> THAT'S A REFLECTION OF
DONALD TRUMP'S FOLLOWERS, JUST
AS WE HOLD THE PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE, WE SHOULD HOLD HIS
FOLLOWERS ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL.
>> IT WAS A DARK SPEECH.
IT WAS LIKE THE LIVE-ACTION
VERSION OF AMERICAN CARNAGE, HIS
INAUGURATION ADDRESS.
IT DIDN'T FEEL LIKE A
CELEBRATION OF AMERICA BEING
GREAT AGAIN.
>> IT IS GRIEVANCE PALOUSE.
, THERE ISN'T
AFFIRMATIVE FEELING ABOUT THE
GREATNESS OF THE FUTURE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WEARING THEIR
FORMAL FLIP-FLOPS AND THEIR
ADDRESS CARGO PANTS.
>> NO DISRESPECT TO THE KING OF
ROCK 'N' ROLL BUT THIS IS ELVIS
IN 1977.
JUST LUMBERING ACROSS THE STAGE,
SWEATING.
>> Sean: I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
THE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS ON FAKE
NEWS NBC, THE CONSPIRACY
NETWORK, THE AMERICANS WHO
SHOWED UP LAST NIGHT IN
FLIP-FLOPS AND CARGO SHORTS,
THEY WILL BE THE PEOPLE WHO
CHOOSE THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO WERE RIGHT
IN 2016 AND ALL OF YOU WERE
WRONG.
I SUGGEST YOU GO BACK AND WATCH
YOURSELF ON ELECTION DAY AND I
KNOW THE EXIT POLLS SHOW THAT
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WIN AND YOU
ALL STARTED YOUR COVERAGE GIDDY
AND HAPPY AND UPLIFTED AND YOU
THOUGHT YOU HAD IT IN THE BAG.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
NORTH CAROLINA CAME AROUND IN
WISCONSIN CAME AROUND IN
MICHIGAN CAME AROUND AND
PENNSYLVANIA CAME AROUND IN OHIO
CAME AROUND AND YEAH, FLORIDA
CAME AROUND AND WHAT HAPPENED?
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT THE WAY YOU
WANTED AND YOU COULD SEE THE
DEPRESSION SET IN IN THE MEDIA
MOB, AN AMAZING NIGHT.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY, THE ONE THAT
SUFFERED THE MOST UNDER
BIDEN-OBAMA, THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY GREAT EVERY DAY.
I DIDN'T BUY INTO YOUR LIES,
YOUR CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
YOUR HOPES UP THE LAST TWO YEARS
IN THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SETTING RECORDS AS IT RELATES TO
THE ECONOMY AND JOBS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, THEY HAVE
TURNED OFF THE NIGHTLY VICTORY
ALL ON FAKE NEWS CNN AND MSNBC,
THEY HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF ALL OF
YOUR DISGUSTING HITLER
COMPARISONS TOO.
JEFF ZUCKER, YOU RUN FAKE NEWS
CNN.
YOUR RATINGS ARE IN THE TANK.
I KNOW JIMMY ACOSTA IS BEGGING
TO BE ON MY SHOW.
HIS BOOK WAS 550 ON AMAZON
TODAY.
YOU CAN BARELY BREAK A MILLION
ANY HOUR DURING THE DAY, WE HAD
OVER 5 MILLION LAST NIGHT --
NOBODY IS WATCHING.
YOU LET YOUR "JOURNALIST" DON
LEMON SAY THIS ON YOUR NETWORK
LAST NIGHT?
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THINK ABOUT THE DESPICABLE
PEOPLE WE'VE HAD IN HISTORY, I'M
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     E
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     T
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     A
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     P
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     E
GOING TO USE AN EXPERIMENT     ,
THINK ABOUT HITLER OR ANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE.
IF YOU CAN LOOK BACK ON HISTORY,
WOULD YOU SAY I'M SO GLAD THAT
PERSON WAS ALLOWED A PLATFORM SO
THEY COULD SPREAD THEIR HATE AND
PROPAGANDA AND LIES?
WOULD YOU SAY IT PROBABLY WASN'T
THE RIGHT THING TO DO TO SPREAD
THAT?
YOU KNEW IN THE MOMENT THAT WAS
A BAD PERSON AND THEY WERE DOING
BAD THINGS.
NOT ONLY WERE THEY HURTING
PEOPLE, THEY WERE KILLING PEOPL
PEOPLE.
>> THE EXAMPLE MATTERS AND
THAT'S A VERY EXTREME EXAMPLE.
>> Sean: WHAT REALLY HAPPENED
WAS THIS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS 6 MINUTES
INTO THE SPEECH LAST NIGHT, SAID
ALL OF THOSE FAKE NEWS PEOPLE IN
THE BACK IN THE CROWD STARTED
CHANTING AGAIN -- SCREAMING --
TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT FAKE
NEWS CNN, THAT CNN SUCKS, CNN
COULDN'T TAKE THE CRITICISM AND
THEY TURNED IT OFF.
DON LEMON AND JEFF SUCKER YOU
NEED TO PICK UP A HISTORY BOOK
EVERY NOW AND THEN FROM PRISON
REFORM TO TAX CUTS TO PROMISES
MADE AND KEPT, CONSTITUTIONAL
JUSTICES TO THE RIGHT TO TRY, TO
ENDING BURDENSOME REGULATION, TO
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE TO KILLING
THAT STUPID IRANIAN DEAL, TO
RECOGNIZING ISRAEL AND JERUSALEM
AS THE CAPITAL AND THE
GOLAN HEIGHTS AS ISRAEL'S
TERRITORY, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
COMMITTED TO PRESERVING THE
FREEDOM OF ALL AMERICANS.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED
BECAUSE EVERY SECOND EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY YOU'RE FOCUSED ON
HATING THE PRESIDENT, WHICH IS
TRUE, MAYBE YOU WOULD HAVE
NOTICED THAT OBAMA-BIDEN HAD
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, 8 MILLION MORE IN
POVERTY, THE WORST RECOVERY
SINCE THE 40s, THE LOWEST
LABOR PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE
THE 70s, LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE AND 51 YEARS, THEY TOOK ON
MORE DEBT THAN ALL 43 PRESIDENTS
BEFORE THEM COMBINED AND NEVER
HIT 3% OF GDP IN THEIR EIGHT
YEARS.
NOW WE HAVE A RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT
IS LITERALLY AT A 50 YEAR LOW.
THAT MEANS KIDS INSTEAD OF
TROUBLE, THEY GET SUMMER JOB
LIKE KNEE.
I WAS INCORRIGIBLE.
PEACE AND PROSPERITY ARE ON THE
RISE, WE ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING,
I DON'T THINK HE RATES LIKE MOST
POLITICIANS, I DON'T THINK YOU
CAN PULL DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT ALL, FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MANY DECADES, IF YOU
WOULD STOP WITH YOUR RAGE AND
PSYCHOSIS AND OBSESSION AND
HATING THE PRESIDENT, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING MAJOR
STEPS TO HOLD OUR MASSIVE
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY
ACCOUNTABLE.
HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR,
A STORY THAT YOU MISSED.
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, CORRUPTION ON
A LEVEL THAT IS SO BAD THAT IF
WE DON'T STOP IT WE'LL LOSE THIS
GREAT DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC BUT SO
MANY BLED AND DIED BEFORE.
THE CORRUPT 1% OF 82 TIERED
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEY ARE FINALLY GETTING THE
ATTENTION THEY DESERVE.
UNFORTUNATELY YOU ARE ALL WRONG,
THIS PROGRAM GOT IT RIGHT AND
THANKFULLY WE HAD AN ENSEMBLE
TEAM, I CAN'T MENTION --
JEANINE PIRRO, GREG CARTER,
JOSEPH DiGENOVA, I CAN'T
MENTION EVERYBODY.
COMMITTED TO PEELING EVERY LAYER
OF THE DEEP STATE ONION AND
TONIGHT THE HILLS OF JOHN
SOLOMON IS BACK WITH ANOTHER
BOMBSHELL REPORT.
PER MONTH WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S DIRTY
DOSSIER, RUSSIAN LIES BY
HILLARY CLINTON, ACCORDING TO
SOLOMON IT WAS NOT THE ONLY
FRAUDULENT DOCUMENT USED AGAINST
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
IN 2017 THE FBI PUSHED SOMETHING
CALLED THE BLACK CASH LEDGER TO
OBTAIN MULTIPLE WARRANTS ON THIS
CASE PAUL MANAFORT.
I THINK THEY WANT PAUL MANAFORT
TO DIE OF JAIL, FIRST ISOLATION,
NOW THEY WANT TO PUT HIM IN
RIKERS.
THEN THEY WANT TO GIVE HIM STATE
CHARGES AND CHARGE THEM ALL OVER
AGAIN WHICH I BELIEVE IS DOUBLE
JEOPARDY AND I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN
THAT MUELLER AND HIS TEAM OF
WEISSMANN THE PITBULL AND GD RAY
THE FORMER CLINTON ATTORNEY WERE
BAD PEOPLE -- THE BLACK CASH
LEDGER WHICH THESE OTHER NEWS
NETWORKS WAS FULL OF A LOT OF --
THE FEDS WERE WARNED REPEATEDLY
THE DOCUMENT COULD BE TRUSTED
AND LIKELY WAS A FAKE.
UKRAINE'S TOP PROSECUTOR SAYS
THE DOCUMENT WAS NOT
AUTHENTICATED, SHOULD NOT BE
USED IN ANY WAY TO BREAK